Here, the answer is 3 times the 6 root of a squared b to the 5th c to the 4th,
all divided by b squared, c squared. That's amazing algebra work, if you got
any of that correct. Just like in our last problem, we want to increase the
power of each of these factors, so that way they're divisible by 6. This means
we need to change a to the 4th and to a to the 6th, b to the 7th, and to b to
the 12th, and c to the 8th, and c to the 12th, as well. This means we need to
multiply it by 6th root of a squared b to the 5th, c to the 4th. We know this,
since a to the 4th times a squared is a to the 6th, b to the 7th times b to the
5th is b to the 12th. And c to the 8th times c to the 4th is c to the 12th. We
multiply our numerators together, leaving 3a in front of our radical. Next, we
simplify our denominator as a, b squared, c squared. We just divide each of
these powers by 6. And finally, we reduce a power of a, since a divided by a
equals 1. This leaves us with our final answer. And notice that a denominator
does not contain a 6 root anymore. Great work.